Hi Kareem, how you doing?
>> I'm doing all right. How you guys doing?
>> Doing all right. Do you have any like uh
way of showing us that the Islamic
dilemma fails? Do you have anything to
bring to us tonight?
>> Yeah, cuz in my understanding there is
really no dilemma and the way I
understand it is uh in this way, right?
The Quran does a general confirmation of
the previous scriptures, right? And then
>> a general did you say general
confirmation?
>> Yes, a general confirmation. And then in
addition to that, it offers a clear
correction of the same scriptures as
well.
>> Can you show me a verse in the Quran
that explicitly corrects scriptures by
saying it's doing that like by saying uh
stop saying three desist stop that part
has been corrupted in your scriptures or
anything like that.
>> Come again. Sorry.
>> So so there are obviously the Quran
disagrees with some points in the
Christian and Jewish theology. However,
I want you to show me a verse where it
specifically says this in the context of
the scriptures themselves, not just in
what Jews or Christians say that would
show us that the Quran is aware that
this is found in the previous scriptures
and is hence saying they are corrupted.
>> Okay. Um I can't think of something to
my at the top of my head right now. But
um what I can say to that for example in
the in the
>> there is no verse by the way that that
doesn't exist.
never let let me finish this. Let me
finish. All right. I'm saying so what I
mean by for example the the correction
right is the fact that for example when
you read the the the
gospel accounts in the Bible you find
the teaching that uh for example Jesus
rose from the dead right it's it's a
clear teaching from the from the uh
gospel accounts in the Bible and the
Quran clearly categorically stands
against that teaching clearly offers a
correction on that teaching because he
say that uh the man himself did not die
in the first place for him to be um for
him to rise from the dead in die in the
first place.
>> He did not he did not die.
>> So that is it doesn't have to say it's
correcting but it just it's you you can
read the two it's a parallel you read
the two and you can see that these two
are this is a correction of the
statement that was said in the previous
uh
>> Avery can you bring up 4157 on the
screen if you wouldn't mind?
>> I sure can. I just I just wanted to give
this definition really quick before you
go IP. uh when when you say general is
this is the Cambridge dictionary it says
considering the whole of someone or
something and not just a particular part
of him her or it so whenever you're
saying that you are that the Quran
confirms as a general confirmation of
the Bible
>> that means that it's confirming the
whole of the Bible not just a particular
part of it just to go on what you're
saying here you're you're saying that
the Bible you're saying that it
generally confirms but like subtly is
correcting the Bible. The problem is is
that as Avery has pointed out, it does
if it's confirming it in that sense,
it's still confirming the whole of it.
So, you've just made the Quran
contradict itself because it will say,
"Well, this part of the Bible is wrong."
But also, I'm going to confirm it and
you should use it and it's scripture
from Allah and none can change his
words, all this stuff. So, even if
you're right, you just made the Quran
contradict itself.
>> Okay, just allow me to respond to that.
Yeah. Both Avery and yourself's point,
you guys are saying that general
confirmation means you conf you
confirming the whole thing. That's not
what a general confirmation.
>> No, no, no. General in the sense that
you affirm holistically the majority of
something
>> either in its narratives, its themes.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. person from from what I understand
the but what I mean by what my
understanding is from general general
correct me if I'm wrong is the fact that
for example the Quran confirms um the
stories that I mentioned of the previous
of the previous previous prophecy of
Moses Ibrahim's aliam all of those right
the Quran confirms the the stories but
even within those stories for example
you look at the story of of of Aaron
right that golden calf the Quran
confirms that Aaron was a meeting a
prophet as an assistant to Moses, right?
And how the general how the calf came to
be. But the Quran
corrects at the same time corrects that
the Bible says that in in Exodus, in the
book of Exodus, I believe it says that
Aaron made the golden calf for Israel to
worship. But Allah says a man by the
name of made the golden calf. So you can
see the general confirmation in terms of
the general state. Just let me finish
last minute things. It stays the people
the stories and everything.
>> When it comes to this particular point,
it says that Samir made the golden cal.
>> That is a that is a correction of what
the the old of what the the the Torah we
just call it is was saying at the time.
>> Okay. So the Quran it does acknowledge
these stories of the prophets but then
it acts as a corrector over those
stories where obviously the Quran gives
a different account. Right. Is there any
explicit verse where the Quran says it
is a correcting these stories where when
because the Quran gives tons of varants
the Quran often gives its own version of
these stories right many many places can
you name me a single place where the
Quran says and we are correcting this in
the previous scripture
>> that's exactly what I'm saying to you
like where does it say that it says the
story and it says oh by the way in the
Torah it says this but this is wrong
this is actually what happened we are
correcting it
>> there is a technical
point that one that the Quran makes when
it comes to
>> never says this.
>> I just just let me finish. Be patient.
>> If you can if you can answer him
directly, that would be awesome, dude.
You can answer him directly and
elaborate how you wish, but you got to
answer directly, please.
>> All right. You're saying you you want me
to give you a a specific verse on from
the Quran that say that it is correctly
explicitly correcting?
>> Yes. Because that's the argument you're
making. So, I would expect to find that
anywhere in the scripture. And and the
reason why we're asking for that is
because the Quran explicitly says it's
confirming our scriptures. Surah 241 447
many places. So if it is explicitly
correcting it, we need a verse.
>> Yeah. Just one.
>> Okay. Okay. To my knowledge of the
Quran, there's no such verse that is
explicit. Let me explain. Right.
>> Okay. So it's is reading into the Quran.
>> You said you said I answer then explain.
Just let me explain. Let me finish my
point. Right. So, it doesn't have to say
that. It just simply has to make It just
simply has to make the correction. Then
you can see that it's making the
correction.
>> How do you know it's not a mistake? How
do you know?
>> How do you know it's making a correction
of the text?
>> How do you know it's not a mistake?
>> How do How do you know?
>> How do you know the author of the Quran
has not just made a mistake?
>> Oh my god, guys. Listen, listen, listen.
>> That's a great question.
>> Listen, the Quran listen itself declares
itself as the authority, right?
>> So, I should believe the Quran is true.
Listen, the thing is, listen, listen,
>> there's no point in having a
conversation if you're going to jump in
and interrupt the other person. I don't
I don't want to interrupt speak. So, let
me don't do the same thing to me, right?
Just so I can respectfully, I look, man,
cuz I I
host here. This is I'm sorry. Your
grace, forgive my insulence. For some
reason, you guys have a tendency of
waffling, not answering, waffling, not
answering, not dealing with things
directly. And that's where we begin to
be to press you guys. So, this is a
conversation. This is not a tradeoff of
monologues. This is a conversation, a
discussion. So, just because Chris asked
something or said something doesn't mean
you have a monologue to give. have a
discussion. So, be concise, direct. You
don't have to waffle on the monologue,
bro. That's what you're trying to do
every time you speak. You It doesn't
take that to have a discussion. Okay? We
want to hear you out, but you got to be
direct. Please and thank you.
>> All right. Make I I hear what you say,
right? So, what I'm asking from you guys
simple. You speak, I listen, cuz I want
to hear what you what you want to say. I
speak, you also be giving me the same
currency.
>> I'm still trying to negotiate.
>> Don't negotiate. We just Chris just
asked you a question. How do you know
the Quran didn't make a mistake?
>> It said that Yeah, because the Quran
said I confirmed the Bible or I
confirmed the previous book and then it
said something wrong different to that
previous book. How do you know the
author of the Quran didn't make a
mistake?
>> Because first of all, you have to
understand that's from under you
understanding what the Quran is, right?
The whole point the Quran the revelation
of the Quran came here as the for one as
the final revelation as the final
revelation. You know that final thing is
not a mistake. Not answering. How do you
know he didn't make a mistake?
>> How you going? How am I going to answer
if I say five words in going into final
revelation blah blah? I've heard these
100 times. How do you know?
>> How do you know? Listen, just just at
this point,
you have to say because the Quran says
so. Just say that cuz that's your point.
>> Oh my goodness. You said
>> how do we know that the Quran is not
making a is not making a mistake? One,
the Quran already assumes the the
authority itself to be the authority
over the scriptures. Where does it say
>> but
I I I am actually the authority over the
Quran
>> and I say the Quran is wrong.
>> Did you know that?
>> Are you are you referring to Surah 548
where it claims to be a muan over the
prior scriptures? Honestly,
>> the entire scripture. The entire
scripture. The whole the whole book
itself.
>> Where does it say?
>> The whole book or just general?
>> Yeah. General or specific?
>> Sorry.
>> The whole book or just general?
>> I'm saying I'm referring to the whole
book itself.
>> Oh. Oh, wait, wait, wait. So when the
Quran is is showing that it's in this
position of authority over the Bible,
it's now the whole book. It's not just
the general book.
>> Not over not over the Bible. Over the
scriptures.
>> Did I say Bible? I said book.
>> Yes, he said Bible.
>> I said book.
>> Okay. So,
>> you have Wait, wait. So, you're not even
listening. See, this is the problem.
You're just thinking about the next
thing you're going to say. You're not
even listening. So, the point is is that
this already this already points out a
double standard. What what you're using.
You're saying that when the Quran
affirms, it's only a general
confirmation. Avery showed you the
Cambridge definition of that word. You
don't even know the definition of the
word that you're using. It doesn't line
up with what you're trying to say. And
then when you're saying that when the
Quran is a corrector over the book, this
book that you don't even know, you can't
even identify it for us, whatever this
book is, you're saying it's not just a
general authority over that book, it's
it's actually the whole book. So where
do you get this distinction when those
words are never used in the Quran of
general or whole? Where do you get that
distinction from?
>> Okay,
>> huffing and puffing is not going to help
you.
>> Yeah, that's not an answer. The Quran
doesn't say general or anything. It just
says confirm. That's it. And then in
other places it completely contradicts.
And we say that the the author of the
Quran made a mistake. He didn't know
what was in the other book. He just made
stuff up. And we ask you, how do you
know?
>> And he go it is not just making a
mistake. He's not pretending to be a
final revelation. And you just hump and
bump.
>> Yeah. Because I I'm someone who who
whenever someone is speaking, I I I
listen. I keep The thing is you guys
keep interrupting me. So just allow me
to to speak.
>> Hey man, you you do that again. You out
of here, dog. I don't need
>> Yeah, man. You better watch your head,
man.
It's it's really it's really that
simple. So you you guys what you guys
are saying is basically this to my
understanding.
>> Where does the Quran say that it is a
confirmation of the previous scriptures,
right?
>> No.
>> What?
>> That's not what we said.
>> I thought you listened. Wait, I thought
you listened.
>> That's not what we said.
>> I thought he listens.
>> You you you you
specifically say that it's correct in
the previous scriptures. That was the
main question that I was asked.
>> Okay. And you accepted that there is no
place in the Quran where it says it's
correcting the previous scriptures.
>> I said I said it and I'm saying this for
the last time. I said the the book
doesn't say specifically I'm correcting
the last scriptures to my knowledge.
What it what it gives you is the fact
that it is the authority over the
previous scriptures. So when you read
the Quran first of all you what you do
with the Quran the first that you do
with the Quran is you test its validity
as its merits on its own without any
previous scriptures or anything just its
merits on its own. That's the first
thing that you do. So once you have
established that it has its stands to
its own scrutiny then you can apply it
to judge what was revealed before what
is correct and what is wrong from what
was revealed before the Quran actually
tells us and the we don't you don't need
the the Torah and the to see to to judge
whether is true or not on its own merit
>> no the Quran while addressing Jews and
Christians says that we can know that
Muhammad is a prophet and the Quran is
actual revelation precisely because of
what is contained in our books.
>> So no, the challenge to Christians and
Jews is to use Can you stop that point?
Can I I didn't hear that. Sorry, I
didn't hear that.
>> The Quran over and over again in many
different places 7157 and others says
that the Christians and Jews are to use
their books, their scripture that they
have in the seventh century, what is
written with them to affirm whether or
not Muhammad is actually a prophet or
not. So yes, our scriptures are the
criteria for us to know if the Quran is
true. And guess what?
>> They differ with our scriptures. The
Quran is false
>> and for Muhammad. It's a criteria for
Muhammad as well.
>> Yes. And therefore Muhammad is a false
prophet.
>> Okay. Uh simple question. Are they Jews
and Christians who have referred to
their books and came to the conclusion
that the prophet Muhammad is indeed a
prophet of God?
>> Okay. Who who are they?
>> No. I'm asking you are they? I'm asking.
>> No.
>> No. No, it doesn't say that.
>> I know. I'm asking are there any
Christian to you three times?
>> I thought you listened. I thought you
listen.
>> Okay. Okay. I I I'll say it to you this
way. Nothing in the hadith or the Quran
or the mentions any person from a Jew or
Christian coming to Muhammad saying I
found you in in in the Bible. Here is
the verse.
>> You said nothing from the hadith in the
Quran mentions.
>> Yeah. Nothing nothing in the Nothing in
the or the hadith or the sunnah the
general sunnah of Muhammad. right? That
says there's a Jew or a Christian at his
time that came to Islam because they
found the verse in their Torah or Gospel
that says this is Muhammad. They don't
exist. Now, we know some people became
Muslim. Yeah. Because they were scared
of the sword. But none came because
their book, the Torah and the Gospel at
the time said Muhammad is anywhere
there. In fact, I've got from the
tapsiers and I can show you even in the
Arabic and the English that when
Muhammad and others asked them, "Is
Muhammad in the book?" They said, "By
Allah, he's not in our book."
>> It's also worth mentioning that the
overwhelming majority of Jews and
Christians rejected Muhammad because
they did not find his arguments
convincing at all.
>> And think about this. Muhammad himself
said that if he could only get 10 Jews
in a in a an authentic hadith, if he
could only get 10 Jews to believe in
him, then all the Jews would believe in
him. That means that Muhammad couldn't
even get 10 Jews to believe in him. 10
Jews. But you're telling us, oh, he's
okay. So, give us the evidence then.
Give us the evidence that that shows all
these Jews coming to Muhammad saying
based on the Torah, we find that you're
a prophet. Where where's that evidence?
Because Muhammad himself said not even
10 Jews believed in him. And it's still
the same way because Muhammad is not in
the Torah or the Gospel. He isn't. Like
for example, the Quran says that Isa
said, "There's someone coming after me
called Ahmed." Do you know that verse?
>> Is he still here?
>> Is Is he gone?
>> Yeah, he's here. He's here.
Lincoln
>> in the Torah and the Gospel. Nowhere
does it say that word Ahmed on the lips
of Jesus or actually anywhere
>> got cut off from my I think my network
is doing a thing. I only
ask about the ayah. No, I I didn't hear
the gentleman. I heard the when you
asking about the ayah that speaks about
Ahmed.
>> Yeah. So I'm saying the there's a in the
Quran.
>> No, he didn't hear he didn't hear before
that.
>> Oh, he didn't hear before.
>> So basically our are you didn't So our
answer is this. No, there's no Jews who
came to Muhammad and said based on the
Torah or Christians who said based on
the Injil and then they give you the
prophecy that's in the Injil or in the
Torah and coming to believe Muhammad.
Show us that. Show us that evidence. Go
ahead. So, I mean, if you want to go to
Abdullahbin Salam and you want to go to
the mole, the Holy Moly, we can go
there. But I want to see what you want
to bring up.
>> Yeah, but the Holy Moly
>> No, I I want to see I want to see what
you want to bring up.
>> He's not bringing up anything.
>> No. Yeah. I I'm not I'm not citing
examples. But what you guys are saying
is this. I I'll just leave it at this.
What you guys are saying is that there
is no there's no in the history of um as
long as Islam Islam has been there's not
a single Jew or Christian who has come
to Islam.
>> Is that what we said? That's not what we
said.
>> Is that what we said?
>> You're not listening. Is that what we
said?
>> Listen, I was not what we said.
>> Who has not come to Islam after having
seen that from with the scripture that
he was coming from that indeed the
prophet Muhammad is a prophet of Allah?
>> Very good.
>> Can you show us that?
>> I'm saying is that what you're saying?
>> No.
>> Yeah, that is what we're saying.
>> And can you show us can you show us
someone doing that?
>> Yeah. I would love to be educated and
show me any companion of Muhammad, any
Sahaba said, "Be upon you. I I I found
you in the Torah now. You used to be a
Jew, a Muslim, and here is the verse
from the Torah that says you're you're
the you're the one or the gospel for a
Christian.
>> Okay. I I I don't Okay. First of all, I
I I know that what I know, you know. So,
the fact that you actually can say that
just
>> I'm challenging I'm challenging. I said
I want to be educated. I No, I said I
want to be educated. Show me anywhere in
your s the whole of Muhammad history and
the Sahaba and all these great people,
right? Any of them ex-Christians or
ex-Jews that came to Muhammad's feet
because they found him in the Torah or
Gospel. I need the name of the companion
and I need the story, please, so I can
learn from you.
>> Okay. No, this is what I'm saying to
you, right? I that's not what I came
here to. But the fact that you said that
there is none,
>> there is none. It just it it tech for me
can technically defeats the whole
purpose of the the thing. saying it's
not.
>> I am I Yes, I I know that you're saying
it's not and I know that you know that
that's not true.
>> Okay, prove. So, wait. So, you're saying
that you know Wait, you're saying that
you know that you know that she knows
it's not true. So, why don't you give us
the name? Give us the name. It should be
very easy. Give me the name of the of
the Sahabi that was Christian or
>> for for example for example does does
that particular um statement does it
does it only you're not going to give me
the people does it only box with people
at the time or is it is it timeless
>> do you have any examples do you have any
examples
>> so yes or no just easy
>> I said I was not going to give you any I
have but I'm not
>> so wait you're not going to give us any
does that do you know of any examples
though Yes. For a reason.
>> Do you do you know of any examples?
>> Yes, I do. But
>> but you don't want to give them.
>> He doesn't want to give.
>> Why won't you give them?
>> Because you're deviant.
>> Your hearts are are diseased. That's
because you know the truth.
>> The fact that you actually can say that
there is none when
>> I am saying it right here and now. There
is.
>> That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm
saying.
>> That's what I'm saying.
>> I tell I tell you what. I tell you what.
If you don't want to tell us,
>> we aren't even going to go in. If you
want to tell us the example, why don't
you tell your Muslims listening so they
can they can feel more sure in their
faith?
>> Yeah. Show Show them that we're show
them that we're lying cuz we we'll
actually bring So now that you want to
go We'll show you where we'll show you
where the Jews said the opposite
>> we'll show you where the Jews we'll show
you where the juice
>> the thing that I came with that I came
with that I started with just to to to
you guys. I told you that from from my
my understanding and the understanding
that I that I know is that the Quran
offers a general confirmation after of
the previous scriptures and it it gives
you a clear correction of the previous
scriptures.
>> So now there is there is
>> there is nothing in the Quran that says
that
>> can I can I can I can I finish in in
what I've said just in what I've said is
there a dilemma in that just in
>> Well the dilemma at the moment is that
you're saying the Quran says something
it doesn't say. So you said the Quran
says general confirmation. First of all,
no. No, it doesn't. Just says
confirmation. Madic. And it says it 18
times. It's very very very clear. Um 18
verses is in a crazy amount of times to
be confirming something. But according
to you, it's not really confirming it or
at least he's confirming it in some
general way. Um but that doesn't help
me. By the way, a general confirmation
doesn't help you. A a general
confirmation like Okay. So what? It
affirms um the incarnation of our Lord
in the Gospels. that confirms what his
baptism, what his miracles where he like
changed water into wine. Um his
crucifixion, his resurrection, like the
fact he's like he has a heavenly father,
the fact that God calls like calls him
son. These are all major themes in the
gospels. So please tell me how the Quran
generally confirms that.
>> Okay. Okay. So the the as far as the
Torah is is concerned, you are you aware
of the of the
>> No, I'm talking about the angel or the
gospel.
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah. We get into that.
Right. So when it comes to the the the
angel for example the the life of Christ
himself like just just his life and his
teachings you can see the parallel
between the the teachings of the Quran
and the teachings of the of Jesus
himself just from his words only because
the the thing the thing that let you you
guys uh I think you pretty much know
this is that the just the New Testament
right as as it is is not what we regard
as the as the angel because for as we
all know that only the four parts of the
New Testament I regard even as the
gospel. But even those
are the those are basically a biography
of Jesus. So the Quran no one ever says
no one ever says that for example when
the when the when the the the gospel say
that he he rose from the dead. That's
not from the that's not from the angel
that's not from the gospel.
>> Who told you know how do you know what
the angel is? What is he in jail? What's
he in jail?
>> What's he in jail?
>> Welcome ladies and gentlemen to the new
>> What is the We know for sure.
>> Oh boy.
>> Ladies and gentlemen, we have a new
contestant today on our favorite
question. What's the angel? And I am
your host Avery Austin aka God Logic.
And our contestant today is
Kareem. So Kareem is telling us what he
knows, what's in the angel and what
isn't. That means he knows what the
angel is. So he can tell us what it is.
So go ahead, Kareem. Tell us what's the
angel, my friend.
>> The revelation given by Allah to Jesus.
>> Yeah, but what was that?
>> Use the angel.
>> You ask me, you ask me what is the
revelation given by Allah to the prophet
Muhammad.
>> Does the Quran ever quote from the angel
or paraphrase from the angel?
>> Sorry.
>> Does the Quran ever paraphrase from the
injel
>> or quote from it? quote
>> I what the okay I don't know the the
exact codes that are in the in jail
because personally I've never seen the
in jail
that's the point
you're saying no no no no cream
let me no cream you're saying our
gospels you're saying our new testament
is not the angel that means you know
what it is so what's the angel if our
gospels the biographies of Jesus are not
the angel that's not it then what is the
angel
>> okay so you never seen it. He doesn't
know. He's never seen it. So, how would
you know
>> that biography of a man is not what was
given to the man?
>> How do you know that?
>> How do you know?
>> How do you know that? Cuz you got
biography of Moses in the Quran. Wait,
you got what Moses did in the Quran?
>> Listen, just just just wait. Just wait.
>> How do you know that?
>> I I I I identified the part about the
fact that we the gospels speak about
what happened when after Jesus rose from
the dead.
>> What goel you said you don't know what
the gospel is?
>> Yeah. You said you never seen it.
>> By gospel, I mean the gospel accounts.
Just please understand Matthew, Mark,
and John.
>> The gospel accounts, right? Let me let
me just state them.
>> You do think it's Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm stating them as the gospel
account. For example, when when you read
and I forgot exactly where it is in the
gospel, if you guys remember, you can
say this to me that there was a there's
someone who who one of the soldiers who
said to someone in secret a certain
statement. I don't know after after
Jesus was crucified there was a soldier
who said a a secret to someone and when
when you read something like that
>> no it wasn't in secret he was just at
the cross who said this is the son of
god or this might have this truly was
the son of god
>> you weren't you weren't supposed to tell
them it was a secret you weren't
supposed to tell them
>> yeah should have just left it there
because
>> there were people there
>> that was that was not said in public
right it was
>> it was at the crucifixion a public event
dude
>> no listen to what I'm
How do you make statements about the
angel when you don't know what it is?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
A lot of voices that are coming
this
question, man.
>> Okay. What's your question?
>> How do you make statements about
something you don't know and you've
never seen? It's like me talking about
the president and I've never seen him.
What how do you tell us what's in the
and what's not when you've never seen it
and you don't know it? That's all I'm
asking. for for example from the content
of the
>> that's not the answer to my question. I
I want to nickname you for example.
That's how you answer all the
>> asking a direct question.
>> The thing is you guys you really Okay,
just just just give me the time to to
explain. Okay, just give me the time.
>> Don't say for example answer your
questions, right? Answer your questions.
You said to me, you're asking me about
the you guys are asking generally about
the cont contents of the inj I told you
right what we know from the Quran is
what Allah says he mentioned to Asab
right Alisam
>> which is what
>> which is that is what Allah that is what
we can refer to as what was the stop
saying what you can refer to where does
your Quran tell you what Allah told
Jesus
>> when Allah for example quotes Jesus
>> so when when Allah quotes Jesus Yes. How
>> How do you know that that's not a suna?
How do you How do you know that's in the
NGO and not the suna of Jesus?
>> It's not How do you know it's not what?
>> How do you know that's not just the suna
of Jesus? How do you know that that's
actually in the NGO?
>> Because Allah would say some for example
when he would say we revealed to to
Jesus the son of Mary revealed the
revelation. That is what you call the
reveal.
>> So when you say he when he says I re
when he says I we revealed or I revealed
that that was the okay. What what did he
reveal? What did he say? This is what I
revealed to Jesus. This is the message.
What is What is that in the Quran?
>> You mean you mean you want me to give
you a specific example?
>> Yes.
>> Does Allah tell you what the angel is?
>> You have permission to give us an
example now.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I I I appreciate that. Let me just pull
one one example up just one second.
>> Thank you. Thank you. The one example we
all really want.
>> I'll tell you I'll tell you what it is
that Allah said that he revealed to
Jesus. Guess what he told him what it
was? He called it the And he left it at
that. We revealed
>> See you later. Bye.
>> And good luck.
>> We revealed the angel. This will be one
of the biggest ever.
>> Godspeed.
>> Godspeed. Good luck.
>> Good luck finding it.
>> I like your judge. Judge by Jud. Here's
the judge by it or you're going to hell.
>> Good luck. Good luck finding it.
>> And then when you judge by it, it's like
psych. You shouldn't have judged by it's
corrupted.
>> Shoot. Oh man. When I told you to judge
by it, that wasn't the command.
>> For example. Okay. Okay, I'm back. I'm
back. All right. When Allah mentions in
mentions um when Allah and and remember
when Allah when when Jesus the son of
Mary said to the children of his indeed
I a messenger of Allah sent to you right
that is that we can ascribe that from to
be something that Jesus said from the
angel.
>> Wait why?
>> It doesn't say no you said revealed. You
said when Allah says revealed.
>> Yeah. How do you know that's not the
sunnah of Jesus?
>> That's what Avery was asking you. The
Quran says things about Jesus. We're
asking you how do you know what's in the
and what's not. You said by revelation.
This doesn't say anything about
revelation. Allah revealed this to Jesus
>> because this is the biography of Jesus.
As far as I know
revealed to us was revealed to Jesus. So
we Allah can can quote.
>> Yeah. That's funny. You can quote him.
But how do you know this is part of the
angel?
>> Yeah. How do you know?
>> How do you know this part of the
>> for for example Karim isn't isn't a
revelation? Isn't doesn't Muhammad give
revelation that's not in the Quran?
>> Yeah. From the hadith.
>> Exactly. So, how do you know
>> what when Jesus is saying something? How
do you know that that's a revelation
that's in the NGL and not some in some
other source that he's talking about
like the hadith of Jesus or something?
>> Okay. I I I I hear your question in
response to that. What you're saying is
you you want Allah to say this is what
is this is what is the angel of
>> that be a start
>> like like for for example uh we have
>> when you want him to at the same time
say this what we
just let me let me for example
>> why
>> we have we have in Mark chapter one it
literally starts off by saying this this
is the gospel of Jesus Christ the son of
God and then begins to tell us what the
gospel is. You feel me? So, do you have
something of the sort that identifies
what the angel actually is? What that
revelation actually was, what the
message actually was in the Quran? Does
it tell you anything like that? Does it
identify it?
>> The Quran does not identify that the
issue.
It doesn't need to do it doesn't need to
do what you asking.
>> Okay. So if the Quran doesn't do it, how
do you do it? Because you say, "Oh, the
can't be biography. It can't be this. It
can't."
>> I love you, sister. See, I freaking
>> I can read your mind, brother.
>> In response, how do we know that this is
not uh this is not part of the angel?
This cannot be part of the angel for
example. Right. Okay. One by the one by
the things that are contradictory to the
Quran. One justice one. Just let me get
to the second one. Second one is the
things. Second one is the things that
were said when Jesus wasn't even there.
That cannot be from the because Can we
do the first thing?
>> No, no, no.
I actually want you to deal with the
second one. The second one. We will
assumption to the second one. Let's deal
with the first one.
>> Karim, sorry. Let's deal with the first
one first. Bro, you said
>> because if it if it contradicts the
Quran, that's how we know it's not in
the NG. How do you know? How do you
know, Kareem,
>> that your Quran just isn't contradicting
the NGL? How do you know that your Quran
is is in perfect alignment with the NG?
How do you know it's not just a
contradiction of it and you just been
tricked? Can
>> I ask you that again? Sorry.
>> How do you know that your Quran is not
just a contradiction to jail? How do I
know that the Quran is not just a
contradiction to the inj
>> for example let me let me for example
let's say I let's say I have a book and
it's called for example the sacred
treasury right and in my sacred treasury
I'm saying that Muhammad is a true
prophet uh the the Quran was revealed to
Muhammad and yada yada yada right it's
confirming the Quran yeah and then you
come to me and say wait hold on a second
the Quran says that It's the final
revelation. Your book contradicts my
book. So therefore, your book can't be
true. And I say, "No, what the problem
is is that the Quran you have isn't the
right Quran. You don't have the real
Quran.
>> And how I know you don't have the real
Quran is because your Quran contradicts
my new book called the Sacred Treasury."
What would you say to me?
>> Okay. That's why when what I would say
to that is is this, right? The Quran,
the both books have to independently
establish themselves that they are
indeed the words of God.
>> Okay. How does the Quran? Wait, wait,
wait, wait. How does the Quran
independently tell it that? How do you
know that the Quran independently proves
itself as the word of Allah?
>> By by saying it confirms cor it confirms
the Torah independently. It it doesn't
dependently. The Quran is saying it
depends on the previous scriptures.
>> Literally confirmation and you're saying
we have no idea what they are.
>> The lady asked me the question. Let me
>> That's right. Deal with the lady. Deal
with the lady.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Tell me how you know.
>> Dude. Dude. Dude, we were being nice by
jumping in because you're way worse off
with her.
>> Yes. Let you know.
>> We're trying to help you, man.
>> We're trying to help, bro. But okay.
>> Get in the
>> All right. I'm here for it. I'll hear
the answer that will help me.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. So, uh there is multiple
ways that the Quran affirms itself. One
is the prophet Muhammad himself. The
fact that the man made uh claims that
he's receiving revelation from God. So,
there has to be multiple you have to
actually examine the claim itself that
he is receiving revelation from God.
Right? That's the first that that you
do. Examine the men who the the book was
given to.
>> Okay? From what I know, from what I from
what I know, from what I know that that
man climbed on top of a 9-year-old that
for me that takes
>> Can I can Can I can you look using
derogatory statements like that? That's
>> No, I'm not the wrong
you you said I mean who says climbed on
top of someone who literally climbed on
top. Come on. We are adults here. Come
on. Let's
>> You said examine You said examine the
man. I said okay. the man
>> I said exam examine the claim that the
man made which is he's a prophet of God.
So you have to you have to come to the
to to the it's either the man was lying
>> I think he's lying so prove to me he
wasn't lying.
>> No no no no you have to
>> that's what I'm doing. I'm going with
you one step because my half brain can
only take one step at a time.
>> Okay. You you said
>> examine if the man is lying. I said he
climbed on top of a nineyear-old. You
said you said to me be an adult. I I
said okay. You said he has you have to
see if he's lying or not. I said, "Okay,
show me where how he's not lying."
>> In response, the man made the claim. So
the claim the claim is very simple. He
was revealed to the he to he was
revealed to this book that he claims is
from God. Right? So the first thing that
you do is like I was saying, let's
examine the claim. The contents for me,
the first that I did when I when I
became Muslim was the contents of the
Quran. Right? the long the the conturan
it's something that I found to be
impossible for any for any human being
to replicate whatsoever. One of the
things that
>> based on based on what?
>> Yeah, I I am getting
>> replicate. So one second. So the way we
know this is true is because you can't
replicate it. Is that right?
>> That's not what I said now.
>> So what did you say? How do I know
Muhammad's claim is not lying?
>> Yes. Right.
I'm saying this this is this is how I
got to know that he's not lying. Right?
>> I looked at I looked at the contents of
the Quran. For example, the Quran speaks
of things that the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him doesn't have any right
to know.
>> Like what?
>> Are you going to talk about science? I
would love if you bring up science.
>> I'd love I'd love it because I know you
know I've studied the sciences to the
highest degree. So please tell me that
Muhammad didn't know science or know
that he knew science
>> that he he couldn't know science. For
example,
>> for me, uh I mean this is just one one
example, so you can run away with it,
but that's fine. But so for me, one of
the examples,
>> we're going to move on soon, too.
>> When he speaks when he speaks about um
how how celestial bodies behave, for
example, how the stars behave, the fact
that stars themselves actually have a
lifespan and they actually come to a
point of
>> Okay, what is the lifespan of a star
according to Quran? Okay. The fact that
the fact that stars die, that means they
have a lifespan.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. My half brain
can't keep up.
>> My half rain, man.
>> Where where in the Quran does it say
this is how the stars die?
>> It doesn't say that.
It just tests to state that the stars do
die. That's it.
>> Where does it say the star? This is how
the stars die or this is the stars die.
Anywhere where it says stars and die.
>> Yes. Let me pull up the verse. By the
way, I know Arabic, too, just so you
know.
>> The word I is yam.
>> Let's also remember that surah 675 says
that the stars or the shooting stars are
for stoning eavesdropping demons. So,
>> we have another problem.
>> See, look. Obviously, obviously if Allah
adorned the lowest heaven with stars and
uses those stars to hurl at demons when
they try to sneak into paradise and
listen to his plans and then he see he
sees him. He sees a he sees a demon
there looking. and he says, "Ah, I'mma
I'mma take a star, hurl it at a demon,
and then you see it streaking across the
sky. It's a shooting star." So, shooting
stars are stars, but they fade out. So,
obviously, stars have a lifespan. After
Allah hurls them, they burn up in the
atmosphere chasing a demon. So, I don't
know what else what other proof you guys
are demanding.
>> Mashallah, brother.
>> Yeah. Wow.
>> Very powerful.
>> If you find that in any science book,
I'll give it to you.
>> Right. Yeah. Yeah. So when when when
Allah mentioned let me I wanted to pull
up the the Arabic because you said that
you speak Arabic. Let's
>> Yeah. Just give us the verse.
>> Just give us the verse and I'll check it
right here. I've got it.
>> Yes. I I'm looking at uh 81 1 and two.
>> 811 and two.
>> Yeah. One speaks about the sun, I think.
Yeah,
>> that's where I was.
>> 811
and two. One second. When the sun is
wrapped up in darkness and the stars
fall dispersing, I don't see any death,
anything. Any any man can look in the
sky and see shooting star dispersing. So
where is number one? You said lifespan
and you said stars dying. So I don't see
any of that in the Arabic or English.
>> You say you don't see what
>> you said something about lifespan and
something about stars dying.
>> Yes.
>> All it says here is that the stars
disperse and they fall.
>> Disperse meaning they disperse.
>> Disperse. Meaning
>> they disperse. You tell me. You said
die. I'm looking for the words you said.
You said lifespan and die. I said what
is the lifespan of a star? Because
apparently this is stuff that Muhammad
couldn't know. And that proves his
prophet meaning.
>> You tell me you're the Muslim. It
doesn't mean die if that's what you mean
cuz the
>> it says over and over again. I mean the
the normal translation is fall and when
the stars fall. When the stars fall. I'm
looking at Pikthal. And when the stars
fall. Ysef Ali when the stars fall.
Helicon. And when the stars shall fall.
Shakir. And when the stars there you you
get Shakir you say and the stars darken
and so on that at least but if the
normal if the normal meaning is fall
Rodwell fall sail fall palmer fall what
do you think that means how do you how
do you think that means stars have a
lifespan if I say they're falling like
what are what are they falling to puddle
of muddy water
>> because keep in mind what we know about
what we know about stars from the Quran
is that they're these things they're
pretty small because they burn up and
they burn up in our atmosphere here when
Allah hurls them at a demon. So, they're
way way smaller than Earth. So, in that
context, it makes sense for stars to
fall. Um, but you're saying that that's
got something to do with stars
eventually after billions of years uh
slowly burning out or something. We're
we're that's what we're saying. We're
not getting that. So, what's the
connection between stars falling and you
saying stars have this? It's a it's a
scientific miracle. How could the Quran
know that stars have a lifespan? This is
saying stars are going to fall. So, so
in other words, Kareem, can anyone look
up into the sky and see a star? Does it
look like it's falling? Can anyone
observe that today? And in in the in the
seventh century, can anyone observe
that? Is that is that miraculous
knowledge?
>> It's called shooting stars. You you
watch them and they disappear and they
look like they're falling. So, to me,
that's not scientific anything. So,
we're still stuck as to what proves
Muhammad what Muhammad said was lying or
not.
>> I think maybe Kareem, you've got a lot
to think about.
>> Yeah, a lot to think about. messed up.
>> Maybe Islam isn't the truth. Maybe you
need to actually locate the inje and
give it a read and maybe that'll tell
you more about uh Issa as you call him
and maybe you should look into following
him.
>> Yeah. And by the way, I don't know if
he's going to come back and listen or if
he's listening right now, but this whole
idea that the cannot contradict the
Quran. I don't know where he's getting
that from because the Quran contradicts
itself. But Muslims have a solution for
that. They just call it abrogation or
some people call it abbergosian you know
depending on the means of this
abrogating sometimes a goat that
abrogates sometimes it's not but the
Quran will for example allow give an
allowance for drinking alcohol right and
then later on it completely cuts it off
it's it's it's over you can't drink any
alcohol at all so at one point there's
an allowance for it and then it says you
can't have it at all but the doesn't lay
it out like there's a there's this like
procession or that there's like this
weaning off of it or something like
that. It just gives you one verse where
it says it's allowed just not during
prayer and then it gives you another
verse where it says it's not allowed at
all.
>> So you can look at that and say this is
contradicting that. Muslims have a
solution. They say this is called
abrogation. So in theory you can have
another book of Allah that gives a
command or says something that the Quran
contradicts and that wouldn't mean that
they're incompatible according to Islam.
So even if even if you could identify
the NGL um Karim if you can identify it
you can't disqualify what could and
could not be part of the NGL by the
contradictions and you're stuck with the
Islamic dilemma now. So that's it.
>> And I just wanted to show you if when
you press Muslims about how do they know
Muhammad is not lying? They can't come
with anything come up with anything.
Like Muhammad could have said, "I like
elephants because they're gray and they
drink water and
he said he said something like the stars
fall." Oh, he knows the lifespan of a
star scientifically.
>> Guys, not notice what's constantly going
on with this. Every every time we bring
up the Islamic dilemma, what are we
told? Your Bible has been corrupted.
That's not the angel. Great. You're
still in the pot of the Islamic dilemma.
You just took the second horn. If the
Bible has been corrupted, then Islam is
false. You You think if you just avoid
the first horn of the dilemma, you're
good to go. No. By trying to argue the
Bible has been corrupted, that is the
second horn. So if there, this is why I
keep making this point. If you're right
about how you interpret surah 279 for
example that it says our scriptures have
been corrupted that just means the Quran
contradicts itself because it says it's
confirming our scriptures multiple
places as Chris has pointed out. So why
is there a contradiction in the Quran?
That also means the Quran is false. So
again this doesn't solve the issue. This
is why the Islamic dilemma works. Yeah.